I'm miserable a Kaminski and I'm the
editor of FT alpha which is the
Financial Times is markets blog we're
going to show quite the power of money
today and the banking industry more
specifically I'll start with the
question are the banks more powerful
than they've ever been that is very good
question on one hand no they're not I
think we saw that very clearly this week
because we saw quite a lot of
fluctuations in the so-called market for
funding which was a demonstration of the
power of regulation since 2008 so much
so that the big two especially the big
too-big-to-fail banks they're not really
willing to take on the risk to like to
manage the imbalances that come up in
the temporary funding market and that
really is a new thing but on this at the
same time their monopolies haven't yet
been entirely broken there's obviously a
lot of challenges coming in on the
FinTech side of things but none of those
have yet really demonstrated that they
can make a profit and one of the big
problems is that because of all the
regulation we have imposed the cost of
becoming a competitor in this market is
huge because to establish yourself you
have to manage you have to overcome the
costs of regulation so in a funny way
the banks have been constrained by
regulation but that regulation has also
made it much more difficult to compete
with them it's the regulation as it
stands adequate enough to stop what
seems to be an incoming recession I
don't think you know if the reality is
is that back in the days at least before
2008 recessions were not seen as
entirely linked to the financial sector
right so what was happening in money
markets and finance was actually seen as
removed from the cork economy recessions
came and went and then banking crisis
came and went and it was very rarely
that the two were intertwined very
intimately I think what was unique about
2008 was that the banking crisis
coincided with
massive recession obviously so whether
whether the power of the banks and and
where we are today with the regulation
and and an incoming recession it's not
very clear I think there isn't probably
a recession coming because these things
are cyclical but the the most important
thing to say with respect to the banking
sector is there is fairly resilient
there was a lot of like speculation this
week that with the stress and the
funding markets we'd be seeing all sorts
of like names falling or be you know
becoming insolvent but that's just not
the case because the regulation has made
it so that the banks are very well
capitalized almost too well capitalized
so well capitalized but a lot of that
capital can't be being reinvested only
in the further economy so should people
not be worried about a financial crisis
reoccurring in the short time like 2008
you see what is a fine I think you have
to differentiate what is a financial
crisis and economic crisis so Connor
come on Mike crisis definitely something
to worry about it means people are
losing jobs people you know are
constrained in terms of their
consumption there's not enough
opportunities for people there's massive
unemployment major distress find a
finance crop you know in in in a in a
world where a financial crisis can be
compartmentalized to just you know
impacting the core finance sector you
know it shouldn't really affect the rest
of the economies so if the regulator's
have done their job a financial crisis
should be contained and it shouldn't
become systemic and nature the way it
was before and if that's the case we
shouldn't really be worried about a
financial crisis what we should be
worried about is an economic crisis on
the point of thirty thousand a financial
crisis before we move on to potential
economic crisis ease so we should worry
about was the response to that adequate
through the criminal justice system and
also the regulations that was
implemented afterwards it's very good
question so I think the average person
in the public I think would disagree
that it was adequate we didn't see
anyone really going to jail
where the criminal responses play in
terms of the kind of legal action has
really taken foot isn't this in the
scandals that came after the 2008 crisis
so things like the emergence of life
LIBOR rigging and FX rigging and there
was a very strong response by regulators
to that because it almost felt like
because of no one really going to jail
because of 2008 the public wasn't going
to entertain this sort of market
manipulation anymore and so we did see
you know a handful of cases of traders
being accused of criminal acts and
having to defend themselves especially
in the LIBOR sectors what emerged out of
that is however were not stronger
regulations they were sort of
self-regulating bodies like the F MSB
which was designed to improve standards
in the industry
and that I think is something that the
banks really got away with because
rather than a new regulator coming in we
got this sort of light touch regulation
and I just wrote a story about how
that's that particular body is now in
breach potentially a breach of ethics
itself which is a fabulous irony because
one of their employees is whistle
blowing on them in terms of how that
allegedly he was pushed leaked leant on
by Deutsche Bank to not give evidence in
a case for manipulation and he claims
that this is clear evidence that the
body that set standards is actually just
pushing the interests of the banks
rather than defending the interests of
Joe public and investors and the reason
it's important is because if the
responses to the those FX breaches are
obviously not working then it's very
embarrassing for the four banker billing
for the government and for the Bank of
England who imposed them and some sort
of new mechanism will have to be devised
in terms of how the banks themselves
have been treated one thing that isn't
very well reported because you see the
settlement cases out of all the big
controversies and
but it's part of those settlements we
have we are seeing so-called monitors go
into banks so now banks are constrained
not just by their own compliance
departments they're also constrained by
the monitors that have been imposed upon
them by the legal system and this is
effectively like a bank banking Stasi I
call it because these are like external
regulatory people who are paid by the
bank but indirectly they're originally
paid they're paid directly by the
regulator's and they sit in the offices
of the bank and their job is to write
basically check the bad bad behavior
with the banks and that is a new
phenomenon and and quite interesting but
the banks are already evolving and so
much as they are they are hiring their
own shadow monitors to try and regulate
the amount of information I'm waffling
now but um but I think in terms of how
we are how the banks are responding that
is interesting because there's always
evolution in this space and so you put
in like an internal police effectively
to monitor the banks and the banks just
create their own sort of response to
that and it's a game of cat and mouse I
don't think that will change anytime
soon which was a long way of saying
regulations are effective but possibly
likely to be gained who better than an
economic journalist to ask this next
question - just drawing upon the example
that you gave in which to the general
public it would appear that the
regulatory boards are acting in the
interests of those who they are supposed
to be regulating - whether it's a
purposeful of obfuscation or a lack of
understanding of how financial sectors
work and how the economy works do you
think that people's conception of how in
the case of 2008 the the banks are fray
and how the economy operates would
change and perhaps be more sympathetic
if they
just understood how they operate it in
more detail I think this is fundamental
the problem is and it's not just the
regulators it's the police
tackling cybercrime as well so so much
so much financial fraud is occurring
through the digital sphere and and the
regulators and the police just do not
have the resources to manage this they
don't have the skill set and only time
they train people up they get poached by
the banks because it looks really
impressive like at a bank that your
internal security is by someone who was
previously a regulator in the or in like
the Scotland Yard fraud squad right so
who is watching the what you know it's
not even the case of who's watching the
watchdogs but it's it's it's it's a real
it's a real problem in society and so
much as the people the skills end up
going to the highest paying jobs and the
people who are supposed to watch them
just can't compete on the salaries and
yeah III I don't know how you can close
that gap
other than appealing to the sort of
sense of moral duty of people in the
private sector to come in and and
operate as sort of expert advisors to
regulators but then there's an a whole a
whole host of conflict of interest and
so you can never be sure if the man on
the on the inside who is helping the
regulator's whose experience comes from
the banking sector is really on the side
of the regulator's it's like the Mafia
and be you know it's no difference to
how you know criminals try to infiltrate
the police the same it's the same cement
and revolving car the revolving sort of
corridor and and and door between
between the two bodies is always quite
alarming and regulators former
regulators going to banks or back former
bankers going to into regulation or
government you know it's it's always
going to create conflicts of interest
and I don't think as a society we
figured out how we can deal with that so
looking through the perspective of
people who don't are people who don't
have the economic theory or
understanding of how all this operates
I'm gonna ask a few questions
and in layman's terms I'd like you to
answer them it's the economy rigged
against working class people yes at the
moment it is and it's because of the way
capital market formation is favoring
so-called too-big-to-fail monopolies and
it inadvertently always discriminates
against small businesses and that is
really I believe that's the fundamental
problem in the economy is that we want
more of Amazon's we want more Uber's we
don't want more small retailers now
we're part of the problem because we
empower Amazon and we empower uber the
fact that they don't make many Amazon
famously didn't make any profit for a
very long time uber still to this day
doesn't make any property at proper
profit it means one of those lots making
companies of all time but we grab the
services they offer irrespective of
whether they're making money or whether
they're constructed for society or for
labor norms and all that sort of stuff
so we are part of the problem I think we
as consumers need to be more responsible
because if we didn't you know willingly
take on these services that are favoring
monopolies and running small businesses
out of the power of the economy we would
have a better distribution of wealth and
yet as you said uber is one of the
biggest loss-making companies of all
time so if we remove on a user basis our
use of their services and we stop giving
them our money what's to stop them from
continuing to operate and monopolize
their coming because uber when uber
makes a case to investors it doesn't
care about it cares only about user
numbers that's the main that you know
metric that they are concerned about
they just want to show that they have
the capacity to grow and to acquire more
and more customers
and if you have any sort of any business
model that has capacity to do that these
days you will get funded on a you know
on an almost infinite basis until you
become the monopolies and investors will
delay the profit until the point you
have taken over the entire market and by
that point it's too late so I think you
know that their loss making but they are
hugely popular with customers and even
though they are generating losses
they're still generating revenues so
people are still getting paid and that's
how it we would the uber model is
justified in the investor space we as
consumers can take that revenue away
from uber and take it to likes more like
smaller companies that operate on a
local basis then then that money stays
locally it stays and it you know ends up
being recycled in the local economy
instead of being tilted offshore so yes
they're making a lot but they're still
making a lot of money and that money is
still going offshore so on the same
question of how can everyday people make
the economy work better for them
cryptocurrencies how disruptive is or
could that be and would that help
everyday people now I don't think it
would help people at all I think people
are going to I think cryptocurrency is
everything bad that we've tried to
constrain coming back at us so we've
just regulated the banks and made it
very hard for them to you know get up to
the sort of bad behavior that they were
used to and instead we've now all those
bad practices migrated to the
cryptocurrency sphere where there is no
regulation there is like the Wild West
now on one hand you could argue well
perhaps that's better there's moral
hazard people who will learn for
themselves when they get sort of robbed
and and and you know pilfered and there
will be a sense of sort of understanding
a learning curve and people will learn
become more resilient and those models
will be harder to distribute in
economies because when there's a
protection in place like for regulation
then the argument is that consumers
never get wise right so that's the only
pro argument for cryptocurrency is that
over time people will learn to be more
shrewd about how they're gonna get
conned but I still think by and large
it's it's it's the worst of the banking
system without any of the checks and
balances that even pre would pre-existed
the 2008 system and that's not gonna
necessarily lead to any empowerment in
my opinion hopefully this interview has
gone some way towards this but what
would you recommend to engage ordinary
people in the affairs or the financial
sector that's really bad so I think you
know reading the FT is is one thing you
could do but it's expensive and I
understand what people don't want to you
know sign up for a subscription but I do
think that fundamentally the thing that
can really improve it the financial
economy at large is if people become
accountable for their own decisions in
the financial marketplace and don't let
third parties take them for a ride so I
would just say you need to question
everything never get like overtaken by
the FOMO don't you know there are always
gonna be suckers but if the cardinal
rule is if it's too good to be true it
probably is if you're thinking about
putting your money in something and
you're being promised all sorts of
ridiculous returns question that because
there is no free lunch and as yet we
haven't figured out how to do if we like
free lunch so just question everything
read as much as you can but don't and
don't feel stupid if you don't
understand the jargon because that
jargon only exists to keep you alienated
and and from asking the really important
questions that matter which is does this
really make sense
Isabella Kaminsky thank you very much no
problem